welcome to this video this is some
coverage of the world rapid
championships um yeah that's a rapid and
after that the blitz championships held
in Dubai in the United Arab Emirates and
this is a three-day event the rapids
five games per day so 15 games total two
at the end find a new or maybe the old
champion will defend you never know
rapid world champion it's an excellent
Leanne yeah an excellent field I mean
from the world's top players I guess
mostly Kramnik is missing but ever but
but they're all all else there there
down the top seven players on are
playing some cards and Aronian a camera
agree shook they are all down um what
I'm going to do is for each of the three
days focus on one or two players that
are popular and when to pick pick out
one or two games whatever comes to mind
maybe for the final day and try to cover
some some decisive games that are
important for the final standings but
the well in the first rounds it's not
then there's already two top guys
playing each other but it's hard to call
any special game decisive okay I'm
starting with the first round game by
Nakamura always popular player lots of
people are interested what he's doing so
let's look at this the field is actually
so strong that in the first round a
camera is playing eateries are gone
maybe not a player you know he's the top
layer from Venezuela and he's rated to
650 so about number 100 in the world so
not exactly a weak opponent okay we get
ready opening which transposase to a
sloth sloth with a six and g6 and that
camera here quickly and gets a very
interesting position we will see that
with
d taxi form he transforms the position
and plays c5 which now it's more looking
like yeah this is more goon fault type
of position with an open center where
the bishop on g7 is really doing
something I quite like the idea it's at
least an interesting way to play and eat
or azhaga is playing d5 keeping it
closed and like I we are in typical
aggressive style as playing b5 yeah this
has some ideas of course undermining the
center and white really does not have
much else Bishop b2 is normal and
castles yeah and now why took on b5 it's
it's very difficult now to play anything
else um other moves really as seem to be
a be helpful to black and provider
develops for example human we lose even
even more time note that there are
tactics already him like this black is
clearly better I think it's just best
what it is our guy did he took on b5 and
after night a six now we see that black
has excellent chance is to get the porn
back it is only with some some serious
risk possible to keep the porn I mean
you can try you for but if you look at
oops night before you will see that
white now needs to be very careful for
example if we consider move like we need
to pluck can't even take care that's not
apparent at first but this is really
possible Queen takes Bishop f5 is
clearly quite good for black and after
Knight takes there is some Bishop b2
queen bee to Bishop f5 again and this is
not not cleared or this position if the
line moves as 92 and if this is played
this Queen d5 and this is really am
totally unclear position yeah with some
really strange ideas like this
very tough to to to to judge I think
it's very prudent what would it to
resign I did you just returned the pond
and right here with rook t1 I think
white is slightly more comfortable is
getting quicker to the central files and
is some setting a slight advantage here
oops this was the wrong button like it
took yeah with an attack on the Queen so
why it first needs to recapture and here
in this position we see that white is
slightly more comfortable that's nothing
terrible rook c8 Quincy for and the
bishop takes f3 yeah debatable move but
I guess an interesting one with the
capture and e6 black is preparing 95 and
now it is our plays in a very very
direct fashion Bishop before just trying
to win this ball and using the Pena of
course like cannot take like a more a
plate I think the best defense 95 Quincy
528 he gave up the porn but now we see
that blacks queen is switching over to
the Kings side where whites king is
really not very well defended this
weekend porn structures not exactly
helpful check this check and Queen h5
directly attacking the pawn yeah there
should be two sensible muth yeah and
here this point I think already Nakamura
could have basically almost four strong
after Roxy one Roxy one Queen inch for
it seems that white really does not have
much else than King g2 can maybe take
for us but we are very likely having
sorry kingi to isn't really great right
the problem is the drug see one was
wrong I read my notes wrong here there's
actually a bishop deform with a great
position from black white is now totally
totally uncoordinated here with the
pawns or pawns a week he must take with
the queen of course I'm sorry and he
have the screen age for businesses check
very dry however he played Bishop fa
maybe to try for win it's not a mistake
it's just a bit risky I guess around
here it's not so clear how black is
getting the pawn back and it's also not
the decisive attack or anything he still
has some compensation but it's not it's
not totally convincing chan-sung some
repetition here and now eateries are as
playing for wind with Bishop a six yeah
white is just better he also had F for
Queen f2 and then Rugare monde also not
not a bad way to continue now play push
the a at the a pond it's not a decisive
advantage and this is what i meant with
bishop evade it's a bit risky but it's
not decisive for white this disposition
yeah after Bishop is a six however
Nakamura could have played queen age
three again going for this this drawing
perpetual yeah this this is probably the
best move after wincham black can play
Bishop d6 for example or yeah okay go
back the a bishop d6 was played by my
camera directly and now f4 again was a
good idea he played kingi too though
after which yeah black is perfectly
alright again get the spawn back and
Luke p8 yeah this is all fields fields
okay age five of course black black has
some instead of age five nah cameras
playing for when he could have
done done other things they're even
crazy moves like this I possible it's
not not really bad but h5 is okay why
not use the pawn king it to trying to
secure the king and queen 2g to making
this push possible Bishop age 88 get it
gets it gets tricky now you should def 8
to cover g7 black also had f6 which
forces a draw immediately but of course
my camera was trying to win you know
this forces the draw because of some
sorry here black must go here and and
forces forces the draw actually quite
quite funny Queen f6 clefto will end in
a in a perpetual check quite quite
strange but ok now camara wants to win
Bishop f8 not a not a bad move nobody
should be fine and this is of course a
very very complicated position note that
by the way the clock times are nonsense
it's just from my import it's not how
the actual clock times were and I'm not
sure however because they don't have any
information about that in the in the
downloaded game file would be very
interesting for a rapid game 2 to know
but if you want there's a live coverage
and they also have recorded videos for
the round so you can actually watch the
games unfold as they as they were played
on life so I'm very much to be
recommended maybe there you can see if
our cameras time was at this stage would
be interesting it would be especially
interesting because right here in this
position it seems that he made a very
big mistake he played rook to e8 it
seems that instead rook c8 was perfectly
okay for black now it's some
quite apparent while this is not good
it's bishop c6 and this was played by
Torres are now like has a big problem
white is just threatening to take this
take this night and then attack yeah
there are there are various ways you
played played through k5 now but we can
look at for example rook c8 which looks
looks totally logical look at this
that's a very big problem for black the
rook is attacked it has no square yeah
something like this is decisive and if
this there's this immediate threat and
don't forget that white has the upon
this is a total win it's a very very
problematic position now probably this
is lost already rue k5 was tried and
after that took and Queen B 6 and this
is essentially a double a check on the
rook and on the king if you want king of
Queen f6 is a huge problem yeah nakamura
played Queen g5 which is not really a
good defense but he was probably a quite
quite shaken by now by the turn of
events rook takes f4 is still something
that you can continue it is lost but you
can continue and in a position like this
like must give up the exchange which
jack is obviously I'm not great but you
can at least continue the game well you
will lose d5 and you can try to hang on
for a while but White's king is
relatively safe it's very unlikely that
something bad is going to happen yeah I
plate Queen a g5 after which Bishop f4
was played and this is really just a
double attack rook oops I'm sorry the
rook and the Queen and the Queen can
yeah has no no square where the rook can
be
covered so greenify of Queen a5 check
and here white is just a look up and
we'll update couple of more moves at
check but right here resigned SS
absolutely no counter play and it's just
a rook for nothing so shocking start
form one of the favorites and a camera
certainly being one of the favorites is
the highest rated player actually on the
rapid world rankings were countin only
is number four which is pretty much a
clear indicator that those ratings are
not very very sound they don't they
simply don't rate all the on all the
games played it's a very weird selection
some some tournaments cowan some dough
and it's it's a bit weird so it's a
slightly distorted view this world
rankings like a more I certainly and a
fantastic record player but I really
don't think he should be higher rated
than cards okay um I did clearly higher
rated not not just five points or
something um ok this was Nakamura so
start the tournament not not great here
after that one two games and he needed
to I need to get back these games are
not in the files I guess he wasn't one
on one of the lower BOTS then and it was
not in the file that i could put
download so we can have a brief look at
his round for game against the law
resume from France just a moment yeah
noted the game natawa are playing resin
if resin is one of the top players of
France always around the 2700 mark and
good work player so let's see what
happens we have this strange opening the
sometimes it's called the new virus off
the rest of opening is 93 96 and
normally Bishop to g5 but in recent
times this Bishop f4 move has become
quite popular um not quite sure why
actually it certainly is an option too
to get a game quickly that is somewhat
out of the regular alliance that you
know and yeah it happens in this game
very quickly we get an interesting fight
present is playing see if I have a move
that I like directly using the center
III and a six yeah a six mace may look a
bit weird but note that one of innocent
move like knight c6 white is already
winning in the game so a six is
basically a preparation for knight c6
and if you play something like that you
also have to reckon with this thing when
the night on a six is not really great
so a six it makes some sense yeah and no
no camera is playing it very interesting
it took on c5 which I find really
surprising in a way giving up the center
now but okay 96 and now we played a 3
yeah it leads to a total mess quickly
this is threatening before so black
really has no choice he must play you
five Bishop to g4 it looks strange
moving it twice but the idea is to take
and take d5 so black does not have the
time to just recapture yeah this is just
losing a porn forum for basically
nothing so deform takes takes 94 very a
very weird opening but interesting it's
probably quite good for white this is
this thing at present in our place a
very enterprising continuation which is
probably not entirely correct it plays
Queen to d5 yeah and the good thing
about an opening like that is there is
really chess being played over the
bought by two people and not some some
engines and preparation they really have
a fight now quickly yeah Queenie 5 is
interesting a text here and the Texian
so check there is some basically only
that with wide winning a pawn yeah
Queenie 60 Queenie to is just good for
white again
so Luke g8 and Queenie r3/y a very very
weird position black took one c5 if we
do a quick count why does upon up so
black has sacrifice the pawns in this
position which is probably a yeah not
really correct play if we look
especially at the bishop on f6 that
makes it very difficult for black to to
get to get castled and his pieces
coordinated yeah he gets some time here
with with those moves but it still does
not solve all his problems jackin evade
must be played what else is there yeah
now that camera actually can take here
leaving this this rook on pre if black
takes the rope check we just get
something like this where white will
play Knight f3 rookie one with the
fantastic attack and he's got two points
for the exchange so this is basically
winning from white to this attack he
couldn't take their played Bishop to f4
yeah and really really a weird position
by the way I forgot another thing in
this position here white also had
another strong option this is Knight f3
very strong move actually but there was
some some very weird point that needed
to be seen Bishop f5 at first looks
quite good yeah attacking here but why
said is what has an excellent reply 95
which is a typical computer star move
then it have to see for a human player
95 you just ignore the attack on the
Queen and put the night only five and
the point is that this is set of course
now winning for white this fork and this
is very difficult to see especially
because the bishop after the capture
only then the d7 square is actually free
for the night or accessible it's a very
weird tactic that would have been very
good for white here black has a big
problem probably the best move
for black as Queen takes d5 and I think
this is just totally totally out there
in no way that black is going to survive
this d4 is falling and it's absolutely
no compensation yeah black is already
upon down but ok this was very tough to
see the captures it's very logical
Bishop f4 and here g3 was played and
here quite similarly Knight f3 is some
is good and again this we had 95 mph
they're totally difficult to spot but
would have been very good for wild this
g3 was ok it's not not winning or
anything but Knight f3 95 is very tough
to see how are you and so g3 there free
white is two points up here don't forget
that like is basically hoping for some
sort of miracle and counter-attack so
he's got some active pieces now here
played d3 and this does not seem to be
right just a move like f5 was probably
better intending king of seven to
connect groups very unclear position in
a rapid game anything can happen yeah
this was done takes and only now have
five yeah Jenna camera head to the
chance to to just get rid of the Queen's
Queen before this was played and queen
before would have just exchanged Queens
and even wide with two extra pawns it's
not a simple technical win because wine
sponsee are all somewhat weak but I just
just counted three pawns at the moment
three even and yeah black will get one
or two back maybe but it's still three
pawns with Queens off so you're not
going to get made it and the bad thing
is after d4 there was Queen d5 and
what exactly did he overlooked 25 is the
only player will move anyway and now
there's this made threat here so white
has no choice right now needs to hit the
emergency emergency rescue but basically
yeah to play this check the petrol him
so very disappointing finish for
Nakamura we needed the wind badly but
only drew yeah in the round after that
she also played the draw against
Vladimir Popkin good Russian gem with 26
40 or something rating and a very
well-respected coach and theoretician
I'm not quite sure if the PGN file is
correct for the game because it looks
like then I camera had a very simple win
in the middle of the game very strange
just just a fork at the other guy
resigns so I'm not quite sure if i
should actually show the game i'm not i
can do it why not it's not a big issue i
can i can do it where is it but I have
some I have some doubts that it was
drawn who we probably just lost you this
was terribly not right who okay maybe I
can can edit this so I don't want to get
to the through the whole game it was a
somewhat offer betweens government
accepted yeah here in this position yeah
Bishop default plate and I mean okay you
don't need to be a genius to support
night b3 and resigns I mean it's very
simple I mean why didn't he play that
it's just it's just winning from black
and cannot really understand Nakamura it
seems have press played this move it's
also not bad for black hair he black is
already in good shape but after this
there is just nothing for why to do
besides resign I can take on c8 take the
Queen and here this is a rook is
protected yeah black black is just
winning in this position nothing nothing
more nothing less it's a really a bit
strange but ok maybe there is some error
here and the transmission or whatever
that makes this this fire flawed not
going to speculate you anymore I don't
know it looks we at night to be three
looks very simple but he didn't do it
okay so I'm going to pause the video
note for note the next game and to avoid
this kind of loud noise yeah i'm also
going to look at a game of the world
champion magnus scales and yeah he has
played decent round a decent day one
those five rounds he's probably not
enthusiastic about it but okay he has
scored four points out of order five
winning hit three white games okay this
is a spoiler for the result here but you
probably have gusts guested that
I'm just going to show you win yeah
Magnus has scored four out of five two
drawers with black he won the three
white games to win a more technical
fashion and one in a somewhat somewhat
more entertaining entertaining way the
two black games yeah we're fighting
drawers ok let's look at this game as
opponent is that already mentioned
Vladimir Popkin so we have a tomorrow
variation of the Sicilian and Townsend
place interestingly enough with a three
this move always had the reputation of
being a somewhat lame it gives away a
tempo to avoid any Bishop before
businesses but it never was one of the
main continuations maybe it's
interesting though spending one tempo to
get rid of blacks main counter play yeah
this year for example looks quite okay
for white yeah he's um he's offering
this straight but it's not clear that
this is really nice for like I mean look
at this Bishop white probably has some
chances to put pressure on black it's
not very comfortable very huge
difference to have the pawn here if the
Pawn would be on b5 black would be in
excellent shape and so we played Bishop
to d6 funny situation also taking here
now so II five was played and this is
now a forced force variation Bishop c5
also was possible Queen g3 though it's
not clear that you want that is black ok
Bishop e7 and now Wyatt puts this night
only for actually like the rights
position quite a lot he is nicely
coordinated has good development NTM has
those ideas to attack the king yeah
Plotkin all played Bishop d7 and yeah to
call it a bolt from the blue would be a
bit much but here it comes Knight f6
directly going for the attack and that's
that's dangerous really I'm not sure
that what should be should be winning or
anything but it's a very dangerous move
at least um yeah he took with the bishop
we of course need to look at porn takes
after that there there are some
possibilities white can try to
immediately take here that's actually an
interesting move after which King g7 is
is best you know if black takes it there
is Luke t3 with the idea Queen h3 Rock
g3 and this is unstoppable yeah this
this made here with with the two heavy
pieces if black ignores the bishop and
goes here I mean kingi 7s one logical
anyway but after this there is Queen
geez Queen h3 threatening this discover
check with the mate so black must go to
g7 and then there is oops check this
continuation again with the mid coming
that means of course like must go here
after that however it's quite funny you
can give that check what if you want can
check check here but if you try to use
the rook now like this there's Bishop
before and black is winning yeah does
this means that here why it must be
content with the draw yes no way to
cover the e4 square in time bishop
jiseop h7 I think for this reason should
be avoided needs to be calculated to of
course what white can do and this is
maybe the better way to play or the more
interesting way to play is the check
King 2 h8 and then Queen to h4 this is
an interesting and well-known tactical
motif threatening mate and black only
chem player 5 and everything else is
made and white gets the
is back and now probably Queen to d8
trying to get rid of the Queen yeah this
is an interesting position hard too hard
to evaluate I think blackest is probably
okay here why the certainly is not worse
he can can can play this position but
it's it's not clear what's happening
really what can capture or can retreat
after which black can be brave maybe and
to capture the bomb it's a very much
very much a possibility in modern chest
that black will grab this also there's
the endgame this is this type of
position like this where white maybe
enjoys a very slight pool but it's not
very serious yeah this was the
alternative maybe the better choice
after the capture here why takes I have
six yeah auntie em I'm black absolutely
must take on f6 there is nothing else he
must take here Bishop h7 chat again the
idea or a possible idea and here after
this if black captures we actually have
this adjusting variation check yeah it
looks like a saurian this this is made
sorry I must go here because I need to
Bishop h7 here yeah this line here there
is Luke c3 with a tempo that's very
important covering also see too so now
there is this and this also in the mix
and he a black must give up the Queen
it's not totally clear this position if
white should win this one hundred
percent of the time but he is very close
it's probably wiser to just after Bishop
h7 step on the side and here white will
probably play c3 Bishop d3 a move like
that at first this looks terrible but
it's not totally clear how bad this is I
mean black can play rook g8 it's equal
material and there is no direct medium
like might get this end for example the
main problem is after this there is
simply nothing else you need to do it
popkin played the move g6 and get this
flat out losers just just like that f5
very very obvious move of course queen
age 6 some the idea and it seems there
is no defense whatsoever try it Queen to
d8 attacking f6 but now Queen g5 was was
just wrong keeping the porn and
threatening to take here and then
sacrifice this is how it went no
witchcraft easy easy to do once you're
you're down with a big attack the Queen
f6 Gavin TM White has a check direct win
taking and Queen h5 threatening
discovered checks King g7 yeah the only
wolf there was bishop g6 was the what's
the main point with a mate so something
like this check checkmate is a direct
made check yo and here check check yeah
here pot can you resigned there's too
much on this hangs this is also
news piece and the main thing look
everyone also so totally totally over
and deserved and a nice win here for for
the world champion okay we have one game
left to briefly check just a moment I
want to quickly look at a game between
bhardwaj abhava top player from Georgia
and very known for us enterprising and
very often simply wacky style of playing
playing sha Qian mamedyarov the
defending world champion so let's see
what happens in this game again this
funny opening it it really isn't Finland
and somewhat it's in fashion right for
those especially for Rapids charm
controls so let's see what happens here
Bishop f5 a different approach we had
seen c5 by a phrase in a earlier yeah
and Bishop b5 is a bit like waving the
red flag in front of the ball because
well one of whites ideas is to play a 3g
form this kind of push and with Bishop
f4 f5 you're saying okay do your worst
and here here he goes Joe bhava is not
the kind of person who declined such an
invitation age 6 yeah and white what has
just gained space on the Kings side and
I really I really to be honest I really
dislike like some black set up him it's
probably not objectively bad I mean if
you give it to a computer is fairly
fairly optimistic about legs chances not
nothing nothing special not an advantage
or anything but it's has black is ok
that might be the case but it looks I
don't know hey don't think that black is
terribly well coordinated this this is
not good here the night on a six it
always needs to cover c7 and you cannot
develop with me should be six I know I
don't like it very much but at first
there's nothing really bad happening
yarrow let's look at some more moves
yeah this looks totally normal 92 yeah
and hear that that's a very tricky
decision now Castle are not canceling
the problem is you would maybe like to
not cancel try to get the King over to
the to the Queen side but how do you
actually untie your position here night
cannot move if the rookie means there is
this pawn hanging so this is a problem
you cannot move the night you cannot
move the rook and yeah you would like to
get rid of the night on b5 but it's very
tricky to do I really don't like that
very much I mean what he did is he
cathode right he is said basically okay
let's let's try to enough right the
tiger yeah its fifth hoping that nothing
wrong is nothing a terrible is happening
but okay first a four make sure that the
night is secure after moves like twin b6
ship to f6 t6 and here we go f4 with
very clear intentions f/4g 5 and so on
yeah and it seems that the next move my
Mammadyarov is leading to very big
trouble already you played night to be 6
i'm not quite sure what you should do
when the computer is saying that
something like c4 is still okay but i
really don't see blacks player why does
the only one with an idea with this g5
push and black i mean for example this
type of position this if you give the
co2 stockfish the the built-in engine it
gives you something like 0.3 0.2 for
white and really waste let's play in
this position white is just pushing on
the King side and you need to be super
precise not you get totally wiped out so
why it seems so much more comfortable
they played 9 p-6 and this is met by by
a really concrete and very hairy quick
attack g5 age six and it's very
dangerous now this Bishop is covering f8
so what is just threatening to take and
queen age seven mate black really only
has this move there is nothing else I
took check and and push the am King g7
if you consider King age eight yeah
there is this stuff from happening and
he have him probably just Bishop f4 or
96 they're both very dangerous this
attack likes black soul King King
position is really not good yeah King g7
makes much more sense chant here Bishop
g5 was played f6 yeah f six weekends g6
terribly but Bishop f6 wasn't really
much better a 96 is leading to a
fantastic position for white the night
is joining the attack and always note
that those two nights are just doing
nothing in terms of defense something
like this year seems excellent for white
rook f1 yeah and and some some other
attacking ideas are coming ham yeah you
played f6 an algebra perfect night to d6
it seems that this wasn't the most
precise smooth night f4 immediately was
even stronger directly threatening on on
g6 that after take stakes we get a
position that is very similar in the
game then they very similar to the game
but here black cam wasn't given a chance
that that he had in the game why he has
just this big attack castles and then
the rook here d 12 g one with all the
pieces attacking that's not defendable
together with the pony
after 96 here yeah mamedyarov actually
could have defended very tenaciously
with f65 he didn't do that he didn't do
that after this which i think is the
move to go to back look at this this is
given as the best line by the engine and
this position isn't totally clear really
black has night sea for coming and it's
it's still of course it's a fight yeah
at least the fried um yeah in the game
he played rukka jade and then night f4
was played intending this direct meeting
attack or night 96 if you want after the
capture here we get to position very
comparable to the one we had before only
that in the other line this possibility
f takes d5 wasn't wasn't wasn't on ya
hear black cannot defend he played g5
after Luke age seven you just Castle
long and with the second rook involved
there's no defense it's just attacking
with all pieces we are blacks PCM here
are stuck in the corner in the middle on
the side of the board yeah this was
played and castles 94 yeah you can look
for the best continuation after this if
you like I won't make an exercise all of
it it's just too simple this is that
quickest way with the Queen sec
checkmate quite a nice media with this
night taking away squares and the rooks
doing the rest of the job yeah 9c former
stride and now look aged 6 funny move it
wasn't the only only win but it was it
was enough in black after the capture
Jack loses the Queen but there is
nothing else of course why does just
threatening this or g6 it's it's
if I far too much check queen is lost
now be three there are many ways to win
this now hope she one question here I'm
quite interesting enough he didn't take
this would have one very quickly
actually check yeah King edge ate the
only move otherwise the rook is lost and
then d takes d5 with Queen dfd for
coming this was a very straightforward
win this being an important point he
played fo the this should win as well
but it's a it's a bit less less forceful
yeah black really has no no defense
anyway yeah he played the King 2 h8 and
now 'if I've this is strong it opens up
here the the Kings side took the bishop
yeah not not really anything else and
now Queen g6 is leading to a forced made
already yeah okay if I said there's not
much else but if you don't take the
bishop white is just winning in the tech
as well look at eight and now simply the
capture and yet now black is totally
helpless against the idea of playing f7
I can show you the general idea f7
intended Queen g8 with the mate rook
takes and you get a new queen with a
checkmate yeah and okay this is
checkmate winning and this check
checkmate also so white has a has a
decisive mating attack in the game after
he takes f6 mamedyarov resigned the game
so quite a funny win here for jus baba
he's always fun to watch if you see him
play in a tournament just look at a look
at his games it's a it's always some
action
on very rarely you see a boring game or
again where nothing's really happening
so after the the first five rounds if
you only look at the players examined
here we see that causal with four points
is okay is near the top of the field
like I move over three points already
somewhat behind he needs to get some
wins in to get back into the hunt and a
couple of players were in front kawana
kayaking nip ami achi nip from yace I'm
sorry they were had it's a bit tricky
this there are so many good players with
high scores I certain I am recommend to
with it official feeder website feeder
com fi de calm and from there go to the
official site of this word rapid in this
championship they have tons of
information video coverage the standings
you know so it's worth checking out ok I
hope you enjoyed the video I'll be back
tomorrow with the something similar like
40-50 minutes of some highlights and
yeah hope you're on then as well thanks
for watching